after last episode's family-friendly
Shenanigans HBO has graced us within
episode 5 preview and I'm a bit sad
because it's supposedly the last episode
we'll see Millie Alcock and Emily Carey
who play renera and Alison respectively
I think these two have done an
outstanding job and I'm honestly gonna
be sad we'll be saying bye to them in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into the episode 5 promo so if you
haven't seen it yet I've left a link to
it in the description but be warned this
is a book and trailer spoiler heavy
video so if you don't want to be spoiled
turn away now lest your eyes be plucked
from your head
child a ton of valerian ships
overlooking King's Landing we can tell
their Valerian by the seahorse sigil
emblazoned on the flag a few weeks ago
HBO released a mini trailer called fire
Will Rain which shows the same image but
with a huge difference five dragons are
missing perhaps they made the decision
to hold off on showing these dragons for
now in the weeks ahead trailer we see a
different angle which also shows these
extra Dragons I'm just curious what's
going on here with the episode centering
around the marriage of Elena Valerian to
raniera Targaryen this is likely the
Valerian Fleet coming for the big
celebration King viserys is followed
alongside Lionel strong who in the books
has taken over Otto Hightower as hand of
the King sir Harold westerling commander
of the kingsguard and behind him sir
Kristen Cole so it seems sir Christian
and Ramirez fling has not been
discovered behind the king is rhaenyra
and more of the King's Men carrying what
could be gifts because this shot is
aligned with the king's voiceover of
proposing a marriage between house
Valerian and Targaryen what we're seeing
here could be a scene where Corliss
agrees to the proposal it might also be
where Lenor gets knighted for the book
states that lanor was knighted a
fortnight before the wedding as it was
deemed necessary that the prince consort
be a knight if this is indeed the last
episode with Millie Alcock then we'll
see Lenor and rhaenyra walking along the
beach this is a really interesting shot
of some musicians among them a little
person for those familiar with the book
around this time there's one really
well-known little person named mushroom
the court fool who provides many of the
historical counts of Fire and Blood as
he was around during this time as well
as the next two kings is he mushroom or
just a musician well we can't be sure
just yet more Valerian ships and a shot
of the king and Princess at the wedding
reception if there's anything we know
about the Game of Thrones universe and
weddings they hardly go well the
Targaryen and Valerian Banners are on
display in the background the Lords and
Ladies of the realm clap with enthusiasm
but not so much this woman who I believe
is Lord Hobart hightower's wife he's a
bit out of focus to her left as the king
ushers in a second age of dragons we get
to see sea smoke and maylese written by
Lenor and rhaenys respectively this is
our first time seeing maylese with us
having previously be seen sea spoke at
the Battle of the stepstones we have
rainera looking out over the horizon to
me it looks like she's Yearning For
Freedom something that will quickly be
taken from her when she marries rhaenice
tells Corliss that raniera's secession
will be challenged which won't be good
news for the valerians considering their
son would become king consort and any
future grandchildren the future king or
queen some of whom May challenge
rhaenyra's claim upon viserys's death
would be the Lannisters here we have
Jason at the front alongside his twin
brother Thailand Jason was mixed as a
potential Suitor in episode 3. behind
them are the high Towers their grandson
aegon would be next in line should
Rainier's claim be called into question
accompanied with the line knives will
come out sir Christian is seen here with
Queen Allison in the book sir Kristen
sides with the queen during the dance of
dragons the Civil War which takes place
between rhaenyra and aegon II my guess
is that this episode will start to see
sir Christian shifting away from
rhaenyra toward Allison and I don't mean
in a romantic way I mean how would you
like it if the woman you love and are
sworn to protect you have to see around
all day with another man sir Kristen
takes out his sword could he be giving
up his position regardless it'll be very
interesting to see what the writers do
here as expected the wedding goes a
horribly awry with just a massive brawl
ensuing now I am completely speculating
here but if I were to make a guess this
brawl starts with someone making a snide
remark about lanor's sexuality in the
book it's heavily implied that he's gay
and here we see what could be sir
Joffrey lawnmouth known as the Knight of
kisses and Sir lanor's lover essentially
this wedding is a powder keg of
conflicting interests and all it would
take is one Outburst like this for the
whole thing to explode Lenor is pushed
onto the table by what appears to be a
member of the Lannisters well Corliss
and renice watch the insanity unfold I
also think it's pretty funny that you
have these yards in the back just
standing around and not doing anything
here's a brief shot of Sir Harwin strong
in The Fray and I don't think it's a
coincidence that the next one is of Sir
Kristen in the book later or Rainier's
wedding was accompanied by seven days of
Feasts and jousting rhaenyra gives her
favor to Sir Harwin instead of Sir
Kristen resulting in sir Kristen
unleashing his Fury in the tournament
leaving sir Harwin with a broken
collarbone and shattered elbow this also
gives him the nickname sir Harwin broken
bones I'm curious if the writers here
are merging this event with the wedding
brawl and that it's Kristin beating on
Harwin here again just all fun
speculation the book also states that
when Kristen was denied raniera's favor
that he turned to Queen Allison does
that have anything to do with this scene
here's Corliss behind what looks to be a
very driftmark-esque type Throne you can
barely make out a white-haired person in
the top left this is followed by Damon
in a cloak which you don't means he
can't be up to any good take a look at
the terrain in the background very hilly
like the veil of Aaron where he was told
to go back to his wife by the king we'll
see him step in front of a woman riding
a horse knocking it over in the book his
wife rare Royce the bronze [ __ ] fell
from her horse while Hawking here we can
see a bow this clip seems to suggest
that this was no accident at all but
that Damon killed his wife to free him
from her grasp and potentially allow him
to lay claim over the veil itself Otto's
voiceover exclaims that the king will
die as we're treated to an image of the
maesters tending to a sickly King whose
arm is completely covered in those
lesions there's something poetic about
the dying King sitting in front of the
Dead Valerian City out on the Seas
Rainier is alongside sir Kristen aboard
the same ship we saw on in episode 4.
Otto says that if Rainer secedes war
will follow as we see Rainier at her
wedding among the chaos it looks as
though someone is helping her up here
but I just can't make out who Queen
Allison's watches as her husband the
king collapses outside the keeps
entrance the Royal Carriage is here so
perhaps he was returning from an
exhausting trip abroad the trailer ends
with Otto telling his daughter to
prepare aegon to rule and judging by her
face this is not a request it's a demand
I'm also wondering if there's a bit of
voice over slash editing manipulation
here since the best person to prepare
aegon to rule would be Otto after all
last episode of viscera said it was Otto
who taught him how to be king Otto is no
longer hand of the king here so he can
just go full mask off is this still in
King's Landing or has he made his way
back to Old Town regardless the events
to follow will lead to one of the
bloodiest periods in Game of Thrones
history the dance of dragons and I'm
here for it that's it for this trailer
breakdown if you haven't seen my full
episode 4 video I highly recommend you
take a look at that and make sure to
like And subscribe I'll be covering the
full season you can also catch me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
White e until next time remember it's a
Christmas wasn't it